respect partage solidarité de vis du bon
jeu food créé par une bande de copains
dans les quartiers nord en 1983 auteur
d'un beau parcours en coupe de france le
club affronte l'olympique lyonnais mais
pour accueillir l'élite
il a fallu quitter son fief et le
quartier des gibjoncs un terrain
synthétique deux blocs vestiaires pas de
tribunes c'était trop juste
on a sept strictement impossible de
recevoir une structure comme nom qui en
plus on voulait d'offrir un maximum de
monde sur bourges
donc ceux de stades adaptés à recevoir
ce type de rencontre c'était le stade de
chagrin beau le stade et jacques
rimbault où évolue l'autre club de la
ville le bourges 18 a été mis à
disposition par la municipalité est
investi par le burj foot pour préparer
l'événement un événement synonyme de
fête pour tous les licenciés
à commencer par les jeunes ils sont plus
d'une quarantaine mises à contribution
[Musique]
et aux abats vous tapez il ya tout ce
qui est orchid donc donner la main aux
joueurs il y en a qui vont faire le
porte drapeau on a nous ramasseur de
balles donc pour l'instant on essayait
de faire un maximum de choses
j'entendais aussi qu'à des pom pom girls
donc après est-ce que c'est déjà non
plus voilà on essaie de faire plus de
choses possible que répéter les gestes
pour que tout soit fin prêt le jour j
pour les petits comme pour les grands
donc on va commencer a déjà placé le
monde qu'on a là un appel aux bénévoles
a été lancé sur les réseaux sociaux
environ 250 personnes ont répondu
présent à travers le département et même
parfois un peu au delà la coupe de
france un projet fédérateur et un gros
coup de projecteur pour les amateurs
d'humour je foute très sollicité par les
médias pour nous quelque chose
d'exceptionnel pour moi je comme ça
contre une équipe tient encore en lice
en ligue des champions c
c'est passe pas tous les jours qu'on en
compte une équipe comme ça même pour le
club c'est quelque chose de formidable
pour la ville même temps nos familles
pour notre entourage c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'exceptionnel à événement
exceptionnel dispositif exceptionnel
avec un gros investissement collectif
pour la venue de l'olympique lyonnais
quoi qu'il arrive sur le terrain la fête
devrait être belle et pourquoi pas rêver
à l'exploit